There is a new mystery writer on the scene, Ross.
Yeah, I've heard this name, I think.
Is it Hillary Rodham Clinton?
Yeah, that name.
I heard of her.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, so they're saying that she's penning a mystery novel
called "State of Terror."
That already sounds scary.
And she's co-writing it with acclaimed author Louise Penny
and it focuses on a novice Secretary of State
trying to unravel a conspiracy
against a dangerously out of touch American government.
I'm like, is it factual, is it fictional?
What's the deal?
Well, it's a novel, so it's fictional
but maybe there's just a hint of life experience in it.
And it's just a skosh, you know?
Well they say the best work is when, you know,
you speak from experience.
When have a job like that, what do you do next?
You write a novel.
And one job I'd love to try is being a judge on Shark Tank.
Do you watch Shark Tank?
Obsessively.
Yeah me too.
Well House Beautiful reports that Amazon has a new feature
that basically lets all of us live out
that Shark Tank fantasy in a low key way.
They've built this new, it's called Build It program,
and it lets customers vote
on brand new concepts for products
by pre-ordering them.
And then if a concept reaches its pre-order goal in 30 days,
Amazon will then immediately
start building it and shipping it.
And they've launched three concepts:
a smart cuckoo clock, right there,
a smart nutrition scale,
and a smart sticky note printer, you know,
like those sticky notes, which has already met its goal.
So essentially this is like consumer-driven.
If someone comes up with a product
that consumers want it, Amazon will build it.
Okay, well, Ross, you know that I love innovation
and I love design, but there are some things I don't think
you want to get the next best thing or the new invention.
You want to protect and preserve the precious treasure
that you already have.
So I really loved this story from Stylist.
They say that the ancient art
of Kintsugi is seeing a revival.
It's an ancient Japanese technique
of repairing broken pottery or other objects.
And you do it with gold.
And it's a philosophy about respecting
and restoring our things instead of replacing them
or looking for the newest innovation.
Couple of thoughts Drew Barrymore.
One it's gorgeous.
Two, it me reminds me of,
do you remember in Sex and the City
when Aidan was making wooden furniture and he told Carrie,
the flaws is the best part.
And this, I think really embraces that.
I love it.
And we are always about the new, new, new,
and sometimes we really have to step back
and figure out a way to preserve what we already have.
So true.
Well, speaking about the special value
you can find in old things.
The New York times reports, you remember VHS tapes?
Back in the day?
I had thousands of them.
Well, now they're being sold and collected
by people who say that
they're an incredible cultural library
which you go like, "Eh," but think about it.
The last VCR was made in 2006.
And these tapes though are still rich archives of movies,
TVs, my childhood videos, which are priceless.
But like, have you ever been like,
"Oh I want to watch that movie" and it's not streaming?
Well, I bet you it's on VHS somewhere.
I'm going to say, I think this VHS thing
is as a little kitschy.
I'm not sure it's really going to work.
I don't see the Z-ers doing this.
(laughs) Well, we can't talk about VHS tapes
without talking about the holy temple of VHS.
Anyone remember Blockbuster?
I used to love going to the Virgin Megastore
and Blockbuster.
You want to rent a movie?
Oh let's go walk down the aisle
and figure out what we're going to get.
It was like this cultural institution
that we just miss so much.
Well now, Yahoo Life says you can pick up
a Blockbuster-inspired eye shadow palette, uh-huh.
Who would have thought this collaboration was coming.
Colors include drama, horror, and new releases.
And look, we actually have it right here.
Yeah.
This is the blockbuster eyeshadow palette, what?
Okay, I don't see the VHS resurrecting.
This is going to happen.
(upbeat music)